So ich bin wieder am start leute
Exzellent ich spiele ein bisschen ballos geht 3 weiter
Nachdem euch das ja so gut gefallen hat und ich weiter spielen will kann ich das auch on stream machen
Alternative wäre gewesen ich komme gar nicht on und spiel halt offline weiter
Aber es haben ja sogar explizit letztens im streamen leute geschrieben so nach dem motto wann geht es weiter
Da kann ich auch im stream spielen. Leute ich bin irgendwie ziemlich kaputt
Also 22 Uhr ist heute auch Schluss bei mir weil Chico was ist los was ist Chico
Das ist geil ne Chico liegt auf dem schrank so
Und kaum setzt sich den Kopfhörer auf macht den stream an kommt sie runter und schleift und schleimt jetzt hier
Chico
Chico wollte wieder raus
Ich bin noch nicht durch bin gerade in act 2 ich bin auch in act 2 guck
Ich bin hier in act 2 gerade
Ich habe die main quest noch nicht weiter gemacht also wir sind mehr oder weniger
dort
wo
Wir beim letzten stream aufgehört haben allerdings nicht ganz
Also ich habe hier unten noch ein bisschen was erkundet aber nicht wirklich viel also wir sind mehr oder weniger noch da wo wir
beim letzten mal
Stehen geblieben sind wobei man halt sagen muss allzu viele
Da unten ist ein verborgener schatz wo er weiß wo er weiß dass meine karte eigentlich
Und also viele quests haben wir nicht mal offen es gibt auch nicht so krass viele quests wie im ersten akt im zweiten im zweiten akt
Ich bin mir nicht sicher ob es nicht vielleicht hier noch weiter geht es da noch ein bisschen was gibt
Aber zweite akt ist ist nicht ist nicht so mega riesig wie der erste akt muss ja sagen die karte vom ersten
ist jetzt auch nicht wahnsinnig groß aber allgemein sind es sind halt die maps
in baldur's gate 3 übelst voll
gepackt mit
An jeder ecke ist irgendwas was du finden kannst hast du die stimmen auf englisch oder auf deutsch ich habe die stimmen auf englisch
weil das spiel hat nur englisch
Als sprachausgabe
Ich habe die
Texte für euch auf deutsch deutsch gestellt vor zwei streams und die sprachausgabe geht nur englisch
Wollen wir ganz ehrlich ich finde das ist die beste kombination
Da kann man das auf deutsch lesen falls man die ein oder anderen sachen nicht versteht
und man hat die ordentliche sprachausgabe auf englisch so habe ich schon eigentlich früher immer die spiele gespielt mittlerweile habe ich alles auf alles auf
Englisch stehen also auch immer texte ich habe sie sogar meinen betriebssystem auf
Auf englisch stehen was vorteile hat wenn man was sucht findet man einfacher was ja so sieht es aus
Ich bin aber echt ziemlich kaputt übrigens ist keine baldur's gate 3 musik das ist
Pathfinder musik
Ich finde weil was soundtrack angeht da leckt baldur's gate 3 ein bisschen sie haben drei vier richtig coole songs
gerade das eine das eine boss battle theme finde ich nice
Aber ansonsten das meiste ist ziemlich
Ja so nette nette hintergrund untermalung finde da war ein 1 und 2 war der angenehmere soundtrack
Ja, ne geht nur auf
nur auf englisch
ist aber auch
Irgendwo nachvollziehbar es gibt ja unglaublich viel dialog in dem spiel
Wenn die das noch hätten irgendwie in sieben sprachen aufnehmen müssen das hätte jegliches
Jäglichen rahmen mögliches budget und und keine ahnung jegliche
jegliche
Zeitliche aufwände gesprengt
Weiter geht's
Wenn so schlecht ich verstehe die hälfte mechanics nicht einer kann ich dir also wenn du was wissen willst kann ich jetzt erklären das
Ist es ist zwar etwas fernab der vorlage an vielen stellen aber zum größten teil
Echt ich finde das spiel mega easy
Ich glaube also ich bin schon gestorben aber meistens durch irgendwelches
Blödsinnige zeug so wenn irgendwie neben dir was explodiert ist und ich den den graben runter geschmissen hat oder sowas
Aber ansonsten ist also ich muss sagen ich finde das spiel übelst easy
Du kannst einfach den schwierigkeitsgrad runter machen wenn es dir zu schwer ist kannst ja hier wobei ganz ehrlich wie gesagt ich spiele
Die ganze zeit schon auf dem hügel das ist also ich finde es ist relativ easy
Das ist gar nicht so schlimm in ballos g3 weil diese die weichen ziemlich ziemlich stark von der vorlage ab
So machen wir mal hier den sound aus
Lasst mal kurz schauen leute ob meine in game sound heute richtig ist ich
Ich mache mal ich haue mal hier irgendwie ein spell in die ecke ihr müsst sagen ob das ob das passt
So bla bla bla bla lautstärke test lautstärke test lautstärke test ich glaube das passt somit der lauteste spell den es gibt
Wenn das wenn das knallt und nicht so zu laut ist dann geht das
so also
Perfekt okay so erst mal paar pets beschwören
Und selbst leute das ist das ist auch so ein ding
generell was die die runden basierte runden basierten kämpf kämpfer angeht in dungeons und dragons
Also also auch wenn man das wirklich mal mit leuten spielen sollte
Diese pets hier also das war ein beispiel dafür diese pets sind jetzt zwar nicht sonderlich geil guck mal der hat fünf treffer punkte der
hat zehn der hat zehn treffer punkte und sowas aber man kann mit pets und generell
Je mehr actions man hat umso einfacher hat man es deswegen ist es auch ziemlich schwierig
Gescheite oder war es in immer schwierig gescheite boss kämpfe zu bauen
weil
Du kannst eigentlich den boss noch so krass
bauen
Wenn du pro runde nur eine aktion hast
Versus die spieler party die mindestens vier hat und in dem fall mit den pets halt sechs
Du kannst das nicht gewinnen dann ist egal wie krass op dann dein boss ist also entweder
One-shot hat er alles oder er wird platt gemacht sondern deswegen haben sie ja glaube ich
Seit ich glaube ich ich glaube ich glaube seit der vierten edition gibt es das ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher
Haben die ja legendary actions eingeführt für bosse das bosse mehr als eine aktion pro zug machen können weil es uns einfach
Op ist so und deswegen sind auch so billig pets richtig gut weil
Die haben die sind tot aber erstens saugen die einmal damage auf wenn sie wenn sie damage bekommen und
die sind wunderbar für fernkämpfer weil
Wenn man also fernkämpfer also alles was alles was irgendwie
Range range spells hat die treffen müssen oder was armbrust bogen und sowas hat
Es reicht wenn man ein pet in die nähe stellt von einem fernkämpfer
Dass der minus auf angriff kriegt weil ihm was in der nähe steht
also es ist es ist oftmals schon
Sehr praktisch wenn hier irgendwie einen fernkämpfer steht man schickt einfach sein pet hin
Und schon muss der wegrennen von dem pet dass er range attacks machen kann gescheit oder er muss erst das pet killen
Und da hat er schon mal eine runde verschenkt ja es gibt sehr viel zur auswahl ja das stimmt
Das aber jetzt muss da war weißt du was das beste ist
Ein toter gegner macht kein damage mehr man kann es übertreiben in diesen games
Oh will ist überladen warum es will ja weil ich wieder jeden schrott eingesammelt habe
Man kann es auch übertreiben mit irgendwelchen utility spells ich glaube ich muss mal rasten ich habe hier gar nichts mehr
shadowheart ist komplett leer meine party ist halb tot
Gail hat keine spell mehr und will auch keine spell mehr aber ohne ich habe noch eine short short rest übrig
Baldur ist teuer ich habe es auf deutsch
Jetzt habe ich vergessen was ich sagen wollte egal
So ich habe ich habe wieder echt jeden mist eingesammelt ja und wir müssen shadowheart wahrscheinlich respecten klar
also man müssen müssen ist zu viel gesagt
Aber
Machen wir aber später aber ich habe mir überlegt ich respekt shadowheart weil trickery domain sagt halt
Finde ich zumindest in meiner party composition sagt das
Okay ich würde sagen wir legen mal eine längere rast ein
Ja ach so genau was ich hier weiß ich was ich sagen wollte also man kann es hier mit mit utility spells übertreiben du hast ja hier gerade
Gerade als cleric hast du ja tausend tausend spells und ganz ehrlich
Cleric ist ich verstehe übrigens gar nicht warum das die wenigst gespielte klasse in dem spiel ist es gab ja so eine statistik
Baldur's Gate Release Letter oder so was von den von von Larian die hatten
Ich zeige euch das mal Steam
Welche nach spielst du ich bin mit der akt 2
Aber ich habe ich habe 70 stunden oder so was ich habe jede einzelne quest in akt 1 und akt 2 gemacht bisher
Ach so ja weil die ja hier
Alter Steam, please
was
Okay, jetzt ist jetzt ist gut
Alle Paladin gespielt genau so und die haben doch hier zu news post gemacht guck mal
Am
Ja
patch 1 patch
Ja, wo haben die denn den post jetzt meine güte
Ja hier das meine ich guck also
Die meisten leute spielen Paladin Paladin ist ziemlich gut
in bg3
die meisten leute spielen Paladin normalerweise wenn ich mir
Wenn ich mir einen origin charakter
Wie heißt das nen eigenen charakter erstellt wenn ich keinen origin charakter verwendet hätte
Dann hätte ich auch Sorcerer gespielt das ist bei so allen D&D Style
Games eigentlich so den charakter den ich eigentlich für das erste playthrough verwende habe ich in Kingmaker gespielt habe ich im
In Wrath of the Righteous gespielt habe ich sogar in Baldur's Gate damals 42 jahren angefangen ich fange meistens mit Sorcerer an
Aber was mich wundert ist
warum die leute
So wenig Cleric spielen klar es könnte ein bisschen daran zusammenhängen dass im Endeffekt
so gut wie jeder mit Shadowheart in der party spielt aber man könnte ja auch mit Shadowheart als
Origin Charakter anfangen und das machen ja auch kaum welche und das verstehe ich nicht so ganz weil
Cleric ist eines der besten klassen die es überhaupt gibt du hast
Also okay Trickery Domain was Shadowheart hat ist ein bisschen doof
aber
Cleric hat zwei sachen die einfach absolut op sind Cleric hat Spirit Guardians was wenn nicht der beste spell
im gesamten regelwerk ist
Spirit Guardians ist mit das beste was es sind nicht nur in dem nicht nur in Baldur's Gate 3 und in Baldur's Gate 3 ist es noch krasser
Ich mache mal übrigens kurz eine lange rast
Spells regenerieren also
Warte mal man braucht ja gar nicht klicken man kann ja einfach sagen lange rast gibt es gibt es noch redebedarf irgendwie
Kein redebedarf lange rast
Alter Game was ist das
Können die nicht die Items auswählen dass es nur auf 80 kommen
Okay, so schwer war das doch jetzt nicht
So zumindest ich speichere jetzt mal und zeige euch zeige ich mal was warum Cleric eigentlich die beste klasse ist
Und nicht nur in Baldur's Gate 3 sondern in D&D allgemein
Also falls ihr das mal mit ein paar freunden spieler so Cleric ist einfach maßlos op
Und zwar liegt das ich mache ich save mal und zwar liegt es an diesem spell
Auf deutsch heißt das ding Schutzgeister im original heißt es Spirit Guardians
Du kannst auswählen was du machen willst Necrotic Damage oder Radiant Damage in der regel nimmst du Radiant Damage weil
Radiant Damage so gut wie keiner immun ist und Necrotic Damage irgendwie gefühlt so das halbe game die halben gegner immun sind
Nimmst du Radiant Damage
Sieht jetzt erst mal nicht so wild aus aber
Der spell ist mega krass op erstens
Clerics halten viel aus wegen rüstung und je nachdem was für einen sogar teilweise mit heavy armor
Und es macht damage an allen gegnern die im umkreis sind
Und das op ist man kann den spell sogar abcasten
Standardmäßig ist es ein level 3 spell aber man kann den auch als level 4 spell oder höher casten und dann macht er
4 bis 32 also es gibt quasi
Ein d8 glaube ich an schaden pro level dazu
Und das ist keine blöde idee sogar spirit guardians abzukasten auf auf viertes level zum beispiel
Es wird nicht größer aber es macht mehr damage so und normalerweise ist es so
Guck mal
Kratzer hat was gefunden normalerweise ist es so man genommen kratzer ist jetzt ein gegner
So ich laufe jetzt mit spirit guardians an den gegner ran kratzer bleibt mal da
Gut die haben alle okay astarion will raus aus den spirit guardians das kann ich verstehen
Guck mal das haben sie ja geil gemacht der haut ab davor
Okay geil geil wäre jetzt ein gegner
Alter was mit euch los warum haut ihr alle ab
Okay hier
What the hell okay die rennen da alle raus ich habe auch keine ahnung warum ja ich weiß nicht
Ließ er laut auch bestimmt die auch warum ist die eigentlich nackig hier bei mir im camp
Zumindest worauf ich eigentlich raus will okay dieser rucksack ist jetzt ein gegner okay das hält plus 10 10 runden und
Normalerweise ist es so also in der vorlage ist so wenn
der gegner
in
Deinem spirit guardians radius steht dann bekommt er erst mal kein damage der bekommt damage wenn er seinen zug
startet
in dem spirit guardians range
Das liegt daran dass man nicht folgendes machen kann
damage an gegner damage an gegner damage an gegner damage an gegner dass man nicht
Wild rumrennen kann und 80 gegner damage machen kann mit spirit guardians da haben die leute sich schon was bei gedacht
Die das regelwerk designt haben aber die baldur skate 3 entwickler haben sich gedacht scheiß drauf
spirit guardians macht damage
Sobald der gegner den radius betritt
Und das ist so krass op
Du kannst das kasten du rennst einmal quer durch die gegner und alle gegner an denen die vor an denen du vorbei läufst
Bekommen mindestens mindestens mal
3 bis 24 schaden wenn du es abcast ist
4 bis 32 damage das ist mega op
So ich lade jetzt mal weil ich meine spells spellstunde nicht verstehen das ist mega op
Und das zweite was was clerics op macht ist zumindest zumindest low level später ist aber immer noch ziemlich gut
Ist spiritual weapon das ist eine
Das ist eine bonus action das heißt ich kann in einer runde
Ich kann in einer runde spirit guardians casten
Und in der gleichen runde als bonus action
Und das bleibt beides glaube ich für ich weiß gar nicht ob das in dauer hat überhaupt ja zehn züge
Beides bleibt für zehn züge das reicht dicke aus für jeden kampf oder fast fast für jeden kampf aus
Und du kannst bei jeder runde einen bonusangriff mit dieser waffe machen plus
Also muss ich dir mal vorstellen du hast ein bonusangriff mit mit dieser waffe die du einmalig beschworen hast du kannst damage machen mit spirit guardians
Du kannst noch pro runde nach der ersten runde
Noch damage spells casten heal spells casten und alles mögliche andere machen also cleric ist ohne miss das ist die krasseste klasse eigentlich
In dem game deswegen verstehe ich nicht warum das kaum gespielt wird
Deswegen ist auch pflicht shadow heart mitzunehmen so aber jetzt war mal weiter lange genug genug geschwätzt
Und das dritte was das macht ist dass du in einer runde
Mitzunehmen so aber jetzt war mal weiter genug genug geschwätzt so
Spell slots sind wieder da
Will hat keinen bock mehr unser anführer zu sein jetzt ist aber wieder am start
Passt wir verlassen das lager
Gut ich muss mal kurz schauen wo ich stehen geblieben bin
Straße nach baldur's gate hier unten ist die main quest die machen wir jetzt erstmal nicht
Rette die tieflinge das machen wir auf jeden fall nachher und
Wir machen es das mausoleum genau da haben wir das letzte mal aufgehört hier an der stelle
Ihr habt nichts großartiges verpasst also genau hier haben wir das letzte mal aufgehört das einzige was ich gemacht habe ist ich habe hier unten
die hütte gelotet
Und bin ein bisschen über die map gelaufen ansonsten war es das im großen kasten kein eigener charakter aber ich nicht
das liegt daran weil ich
es etwas
blöde finde
Dass es nur vier charakter slots gibt
Übrigens leid ist auch was was ich jedem empfehlen kann
weil
Menschen sehen in der dunkelheit nix standardmäßig
Halbelf sehen in der dunkelheit glaube ich und
Tieflinge sehen auch haben auch dark vision aber die zwei menschen hier die sehen in der dunkelheit nix deswegen ist
leid ziemlich sinnig mitzunehmen
Genau ja der grund warum ich keinen eigenen charakter habe weil
Das spiel hat nur vier vier eine vierer party die alten baldur's gale eine sechser party ich habe darauf spekuliert dass sie mindestens
Eine fünfer party haben einfach weil du mehr möglichkeiten hast
Und um maximal story mitzubekommen und nachdem du eigentlich mit gail und shadowheart spielen musst wenn du ein halbwegs
Gescheite party haben möchtest
Und der rest kann es dir aussuchen du brauchst du brauchst ein wizard du brauchst ein cleric kommst du nicht drumherum
Du brauchst irgendeinen tank oder sag mal irgendeinen nahkampf damage dealer schrägstrich tank kannst du khalek oder liessel benutzen
Und der vierte slot ist optional so und ich dachte mir halt wenn eh schon mehr oder weniger die party composition
Fast fest steht die man spielen muss will ich jetzt nicht noch
Ne du hast nicht verkackt warum nein quatsch du kannst das auch mit einem eigenen charakter spielen
90 prozent der leute spielen das mit einem eigenen charakter überhaupt kein problem wenn es ein gescheiter charakter ist du hast ja noch
Einen vierten slot frei der frei wählbar ist kannst ja für deinen eigenen charakter benutzen
Und
Ich dachte mir halt wenn ich keinen eigenen charakter benutze bekomme ich maximal story mit
Und bin noch ein bisschen flexibler was ich an companions mitnehmen kann
So wir machen jetzt das mausoleum da sind das letzte mal stehen geblieben
Da geht es rein gucken was es da gibt
safe und danach respekten wir shadow heart
Weil ich habe festgestellt dass trickery domain einfach sagt gerade für meine party composition ich bin halt nicht irgendwie
so
Schleichmäßig unterwegs wie viele akte hat das game ich glaube drei
Und und es gibt wohl
Ich bin mir nicht sicher ob es noch so eine art outro akt gibt
Aber ich glaube es gelesen zu haben es sind quasi wenn man wenn man so die ganzen
Zwischendinger mitrechnen sind sie irgendwie so dreieinhalb aber ich glaube offiziell sind es drei
Was stand da gerade überfüllt
Überfüllte kann er kommen dieser bereich ist mit den knochen der toten überfüllt der zauber tote beleben
Skelette
Erfordert kein skelett um die toten diesen bereich zu erwecken okay nice finde ich gut dann kann shadow hart gleich mal
Das muss ich mir nicht das kram machen
Dann
Bin nicht sicher was davon besser ist
Jeder beschwören wir doch einfach mal ein skelett
Wenn es umsonst ist warum nicht
Okay, was gibt es hier denn
Hier geht es zur main quest raus
Nichts weihrauch gleich kommt der papst
Was was schlurft dann das ist mein mein skelett und kann sagen was macht das so komische erst mal eine runde ausruhen
Kann das sein dass die map gar nicht so groß ist dass das im prinzip quasi soll ich sagen ein
Bosskampf in der mitte ist und das war es
Das muss man mal kurz erkunden
Ich werde mal das tor aufmachen
Mein pet
Von alleine abmachen unsichtbar und mal gucken was hier so abgeht
Oh guck mal
Ein redender redender schädel das wäre ein licht oder sowas aber ist es nicht
Irgendein irgendein redendes fiech was ich getriggert habe mit meinem unsichtbaren pet
Ich stelle sie erst mal mit meinem pet durch ich will erst mal gucken was da los ist
Tagebuch dreiteil rucksack ja gut mein pet kann leider nichts nicht auf nicht aufheben
Und das könnte ich jetzt hier schon mal könnte ich jetzt mal alles looten aber das pet kann nicht interagieren was was auch okay ist
Weil das wäre ziemlich op wenn das pet stelle ich mal vor das pet könnte buttons drücken und sowas
Da könntest du das halbe game skippen wobei habt ihr den speed chat hat jemand von euch den speedrun gesehen
Oder einen der speedrun speedruns die skippen halt einfach das halbe game
Nee hier ist nix okay
Am besten ist ja immer noch speedrun 6 any%
Wo man sich wo man sich fragt wer es da wieder drauf gekommen war
Wobei muss man sich nicht lange fragen ist eigentlich naheliegend in dem game gut hier ist nix dann wird mein pet wieder angeleint
Und wir gehen hier mal rein ich fürchte ja
Sobald ich hier reingehe triggert irgendwas und will rede mal mit dem
Geht nicht war jetzt ich mache jetzt den sag auf und werde garantiert irgendwas triggern an gegnern
Und
Okay man kann den sag nicht öffnen
Es ist total bescheuert in dem larien game alle wasen anzuklicken das ist total unsinnig
Aber hat noch jemand diesen tick dass er alles anklicken muss
Auf
Man spielt zu starfield wahrscheinlich gar nicht weiß es ist heute rausgekommen, aber es juckt mich ehrlich gesagt nicht wirklich
So wir haben advantage auf
Guidance advantage auf schlösser knacken
alter gail
Na gut noch mal
Okay jetzt aber fließt bloß vier jahre das passt also für advantage war das schon eben richtig mies
Was haben guck mal da blendender umhang
Du erhältst sieben temporäre trefferpunkte nachdem du im nacken was nachdem du im nahkampf zauber gewickt hast
Unsinnig ich wirke nicht im nahkampf zauber auf der anderen seite das könnte man tatsächlich
Gail anziehen einfach nur just for fun weil gail hat noch kein umhang an
Gail hat die hässlichste rüstung ever aber die rüstung hat mega stats
Die hat zu überlegen dass das eigentlich übelst op du kriegst plus zwei decks
Und advantage auf
Geschicklichkeitswürfe plus zwei decks bedeutet automatisch
eine rüstungsklasse mehr weil das 18 decks und wenn du nur
normale stoffkleidung an hast ist jeder
Punkt also alle zwei punkte decks automatisch ein ein
armor class
Punkt und dementsprechend ist das ziemlich ziemlich gut für gail
Leckiges
Ist das nicht ich klicke die bücher immer nur an dass ich irgendwelche questnotizen bekomme sollte es damit was zu tun haben
Okay
Erst erstmal alle uhren aufmachen hier war
Guck mal da
Schnell hat was los
Kristallinsel
Damit ist ein bisschen gold okay
Why not?
Moment das hat das game grad zusätzlich noch automatisch gespeichert oder hat einfach nur lange gebraucht
Hiding inside
Okay, das ist doch nicht nur so eine kleine map da ist da ist noch mehr okay ich mache jetzt nicht alle wasen auf
Mein skelett verwirrt mich dass das immer irgendwelche mob sounds macht hier ist nix hier ist
Knochen wer hätte das gedacht
Er legt hier
Traps wo sind traps oh traps
Okay gelb lasst deine
Oh jetzt habe ich mit kala
Ist schon geil oder
Gail ist der beste entschärfer dude bei mir in der party dank. Oh guck mal da ist ein knopf
Was macht denn der knopf ist immer gefährlich einfach random knöpfe zu drücken
Ich glaube der knopf wäre um die falle auszuschalten falls man die falle ausgelöst hat
Leute ich rieche ein schalter rätsel ihr auch
Da bin ich immer richtig schlecht drin in solchen sachen
Ich verkack eigentlich so ziemlich alles was man verkacken kann was irgendwelche schalter rätsel und so angeht
Oder ist aber mies aber wir können es trotzdem packen ja vier und nochmal drei
Easy diffuse
Ich entschärfe mal schnell ich bin nicht ganz sicher was passiert ist aber
Erst mal erst mal entschärfer dude entschärfen lassen
Entschärfen lassen hinten ist noch ein knopf
Ist ja alles voll
Aber gelb ist der beste entschärfer hier der hat es drauf
Wer braucht irgendein rogue oder sonst was wenn auch einfach der wizard mit viel decks entschärfen kann
Er hat du hast recht die rüstung ist mega hässlich aber die stats sind halt gut
Ich hoffe ja dass es irgendwie so einen transmog mod geben wird für baldur's gate 3 dass man
dass man einfach die rüstung umstylen kann weil ganz ehrlich die rüstung hat mega stats aber sieht halt kacke aus
Was haben wir hier?
Anführer
Leute ich rieche ich rieche irgendein schalter rätsel
Kann man die ausschalten wenn man die wieder ausschalten kann
Okay man kann die nicht ausschalten dann ist es auch kein schalter rätsel weil schalter rätsel erfordern dass man irgendwelche sachen an ausschalten kann
Alter wie viele feilen sind hier bitte schön
Aber gelb kann so gut wie nicht fehlen bei 10 erwürfen
Ich müsste mal ausrechnen wie hoch da die chancen sind aber mit advantage plus plus 4 und noch mal
1 d 4 kann eigentlich nichts schief gehen
Es gibt ein transmog mod echt
nice
Muss ich mal ausprobieren ich will erst mal keine mods installieren weil ich bin nicht sicher bin wie stabil das game danach ist
Das game hatte jetzt schon ein paar
stability problems
Beispielsweise vielleicht hat das ja auch schon jemand von euch wenn ihr manchmal wenn ihr spiele ladet
Dann lädt es einfach nicht also dann hängt es vor allem wenn gerade der der runde als der fight angefangen hat und ihr ladet dann
Kackt es manchmal ab
Bleibt unendlich im hängen
Unendlich im ladebildschirm hängen
Sind jetzt sind jetzt alle traps weg
Habe ich habe ich es irgendwann mal ja
Hoffe ich
Oh shit
Oh ja
Ja entschärfen
Doch nicht doch nicht spielst du mit valken oder direkt x ich glaube direkt x macht doch im prinzip keinen großen unterschied
Okay kann man irgendwie
Es ist weg okay
Ist weg das haben wir hier türme nee doch ja ist gut
Wo kommt wo kommt denn das her
Ja müsste hier müsste doch irgendwas auf dem boden sein wo das rauskommt
irgendwas zum diffusen noch
Okay, ich habe alles angeklickt hier drauf hier drauf hier drauf
Es ist aber irgendwie nichts passiert
Oh doch ein schalter rätsel guck mal das ist wieder ausgegangen
Okay doch schalter rätsel okay so wie ich mir gedacht habe schalter rätsel
Wir müssen das bestimmten der richtigen reihenfolge drücken okay das ist jetzt ist es angeblieben
Okay schalter rätsel gelöst easy
Du bist unzufrieden mit der party
Ja, du musst mindestens gail und shadowheart einpacken
Ohne kannst du richtig spielen
Das war das war falsch oder
Okay dann eben zuerst zuerst den turm
Dann den kummer
Und dann ich meine viel viel durchprobieren möglichkeiten haben wir ja nicht und dann und dann den general
Leute
Irgendwie könnte man diese schalter rätsel garantiert lesen erlösen mit irgendeinem lesen von irgendeinem buch was hier rumliegt aber man kann schalter
rätsel auch einfach durchprobieren
Sich nicht darum kümmern was hier was hier sonst auch rumliegt
So habe ich irgendwas vergessen auf der map
kurz schauen
Hier war nix
Hier hinten sieht es ein bisschen aus als ging es da weiter aber ist wahrscheinlich nicht so
So gelb du darfst auch noch mal dein pet beschwören
Ja dark urges glaube ich nicht so geil für erstes playthrough auf der anderen seite
Kannst ja du kannst dir derzeit respekten also
Ich meine du brauchst geil nicht wenn du selbst sorcerer oder oder wizard bist
Fehlgeschlagen fehlgeschlagen fehlgeschlagen fehlgeschlagen erfolgreich heißt noch mal buddeln eine runde dicken
aber hier flimmern
Was war kurz schauen ob geil irgendwelche neuen zauber lernen kann
Ansonsten passt das soweit
Dann würde ich sagen fahren wir doch mal mit dem fahrstuhl runter
Also das sollte ja alles nicht main quest sein
Das ist alles irgendwelche irgendwelche side side content
Drei journal einträgen ok es hat sich aktualisiert
Frag mich nur was sich aktualisiert hat
Ein schar temple oder das findet shadow heart bestimmt ganz furchtbar geil
Da geht er jetzt richtig eine abglei
Morgen mag sie starte morgen meinen neuen job
Hast du irgendwelche tipps beziehungsweise konkreten tipps wie man sich am besten vorstellt
Naja gut das vorstellen dich rumführen und zeigen wird ja wahrscheinlich dein chef machen
Du solltest
Die erste woche dazu nutzen zu gucken ob alle deine zugänge gehen
Dass dein desktop pc geht oder dein notebook dass du überall zugänge hast dass du ein bisschen gefühl dafür bekommt wieder laden läuft
Was man am besten nicht machen sollte und sowas viel arbeiten wirst du die erste woche nicht
Welche quest haben sich jetzt eigentlich aktualisiert ok ja das haben wir gemacht main quest
Tempel das schar ist temple voll schar da sind wir wahrscheinlich jetzt ja das ist auch aktualisiert
Und wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich ist shadow heart personal quest
Ok das hat sich auch aktualisiert ok
Berge die abgeschlossen ja wirklich viel bringen tut es jetzt ja auch nicht
Guck mal kann man kann man irgendwie runterporten
Ok leute ich fürchte ja das ist ein bug
Wenn ach jetzt ist sie wenn ich porti hierhin und will stirbt ich sehe vorher noch mal auf
Falscher knopf
Das ist bestimmt ein bug aber wenn nicht und da unten gibt es irgendwas muss ich jetzt mal hin porten
Deswegen ist die steppe beste
Ohne ohne miss die steppe gehe ich nicht aus dem haus also hier den den spell hier
Und am besten auf allen charakteren auf hier auf meinem charakter habe ich sogar zweimal
Gail hat den als spell hat den als spell sogar sogar shadow heart hat
Ein item mit mit miss die steppe generell ist ballos geht sehr freundlich was movement spells angeht
Ok will
Ok will ist der
He doesn't know he lacks critical information
Gut das dachte ich mir fast schon dass es ein bug ist dass man darunter teleportieren kann
Bei eindeutigen boden wo man hin kann es macht es macht nicht wirklich sinn dass will stirbt
Außer dass es halt einfach so out of map zone ist und man instant stirbt
Das sind übrigens auch zu die einzigen gründe wo ich wo ich neu lade ansonsten
Also wenn irgendwas passiert wo ich halt nichts für kann
Hast du mit will angefangen nee Gail ist mein main charakter
Will also der grund warum ich die party habe ist folgendes wizard und cleric ohne kannst du nicht spielen also sagen wir so
Du kannst ohne cleric nicht spielen du kannst ohne sorcerer oder wizard nicht gescheit spiel als die zwei brauchst du brauchst ein melee
tank schräg schräg melee damage dealer charakter und will habe ich dabei weil
Will äußerst charismatisch ist
Und das ist immer ganz gut wenn man einen charakter dabei hat der viel charisma hat und vorne wegläuft
Weil der eben gut im labern ist
Das wäre ein faires geld für ein physi nach der abgeschlossenen ausbildung
Also ich kann ja immer nur sagen was ich verdient habe ich habe 33,5 verdient aber das ist schon 15 jahre her
Kannst jetzt hochrechnen inflationen mäßig dann
Weißt du ungefähr mit was ich damals angefangen habe
Es kommt extrem darauf an welche branche welches bundesland. Oh was gibt es hier
Schatten edelstein
Shadowheart was sagst du eigentlich dazu dass wir im tempel tempel von schar sind
Ich kann es nicht glauben. Ich kann es nicht glauben, dass wir die dunkle Justizarin gefunden haben
Haben wir das
Dies ist der ort an dem ihr dunkle justizarin werden könnt vielleicht wird euer traum war sagt mir was ihr von diesem ort wisst
Es ist der höchste test der dunklen justizarin
Um zu beurteilen ob sie wertvoll sind um eine dunkle justiz zu werden. Der gondel hat einen zweifel
Es spricht von den ordentlichen zu überwachen und der armbandte Fiste von Lady Schar die sich immer über Zeit verloren haben
Jetzt beurteilen man den Rang einfach durch einen einzigen Saloon Knight zu töten
aber vorher
waren sie eine wahre Elite viele würden die Tests versuchen, aber wenige würden es erreichen
Also shadowheart darf wenn es nach mir geht gerne dunkler
Dunkle Justizarin werden da gibt es bestimmt ordentliche Statspony oder sowas
Ich will über all das reden was nein will ich nicht
Ich wollte einfach nur wissen was sie zu dem Tempel sagt
wow
Won't guess
Okay, da darf bestimmt nur Shadowheart ran. Pass mal auf, das ist bestimmt so gemacht, dass nur Shadowheart ran darf
Nein, Shadowheart darf auch nicht ran
Okay
Okay, Moment, fixen wir jetzt aus
Wait a minute, ich stelze nur ich wollte ich wollte rundenbasierten Modus anmachen
Okay
Hey
Ich habe rundenbasierten Modus an, du kannst nicht in der gleichen Runde zweimal was machen. Anzeige ist raus
Okay, dann geht das nicht
Was passiert mit meinem Pet? Ach, mein Pet darf hinfliegen. Ah, so ist das also
Ach ja auch nicht. Okay, ich glaube wir dürfen da nicht, wir dürfen da nicht ran
Jetzt da gibt es bestimmt irgendeinen Trick. Können wir das Ding kaputt machen?
Nein
Okay, wir müssen wahrscheinlich dran vorbeilaufen und
What the f...
Wahrnehmung fehlgeschlagen. Oh, oh, oh, was ist hier?
Was?
What is happening?
So, erstmal eine Runde entschärfen, aber nicht mit Will. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nicht, nicht, nicht, na okay
Dann machen wir das jetzt doch mit Will
Und direkt verkackt
Ja
Okay, Gale
Alter
Kein Fallenentschärfer-Werkzeug
Wie jetzt? Man kann die Würfelfarbe ändern, ja. Wie, ich habe keinen Fallenentschär...
Warum nicht? Eben hatte ich doch noch welche. Kann das sein, dass ich eben alle verbraucht habe, die ich habe? Ja, das ist natürlich, das ist natürlich doof
Ich brauche auf jeden Fall was zum Entschärfen
Ohne Entschärfung kommst du hier nicht richtig durch
Ich blöcke gerade nicht so wirklich durch, warum das jetzt in Rundenmodus gegangen ist. Ah, passiert ja nix
Ach, wegen der Falle
Oh, Gale ist am abkacken
Okay, ich muss, ich muss erstmal, ich muss Fallenentschärfungszeug einkaufen, weil so kannst du es knicken
Ja, wir brauchen Fallenentschärfung
Ja, wir brauchen Fallenentschärfungs-Kram. Ist aber kein Ding, wir sind relativ schnell wieder hier. Wir gehen jetzt
ins Gasthaus zum Händler
Und kaufen uns ein paar Fallenentschärfung-Sets
Lasst mal eure Ware... Was? Game!
Fallenentschärfung-Set... Hat die sowas?
Hat die nicht? Wie, man muss das doch irgendwo herkriegen. Oder sehe ich's bloß nicht
Kann es sein, dass... Ah, hier! Fallenentschärfer-Werkzeug
Okay, das sind nur drei
Ist jetzt nicht so geil
Aber why not
Besser als nix
Besser als nix und dann lass mal kurz ins Lager gucken, ob ich noch welche hab
Wo ist die Kiste?
Aber ich glaube, ich glaube das Game benutzt so Sachen auch aus ner Kiste raus
Nicht, nicht sicher
Falls ich noch was in der Kiste hab
Typ
Rucksack in Rucksack, sehr schlau Max
Irgendwie ist das Game grad ein bisschen broken
Wie ich einfach random Sachen hier im Rucksack hab
Hab ich noch Entschärfer-Sets
Seht ihr irgendwas? Ich nicht
Man kann ja leider nicht suchen in der Kiste, das find ich ein bisschen...
Ein bisschen blöd
Aber was wir machen können ist
Wir nehmen mal einen Charakter, der nicht wirklich viel drauf hat
Zum Beispiel Shadowheart
Shadowheart darf das alles in die Kiste legen
Und dann geht Shadowheart zur Kiste
Was hat Voloart? Voloart hat was zu verkaufen
So und jetzt
So, Shadowheart hat das
Hat nur die Resurrection Scrolls
Alles nehmen bei Shadowheart in den Rucksack
Jetzt hängt das Game
Oh das Game sübelt es am abkacken
Ich hoffe es ist nicht gecrashed jetzt dadurch
Ah jetzt gehts, ok
Pallen-Entschärfer-Werkzeug
Da hab ich dann auch 4 Stück
Perfekt
So und jetzt haben wir wieder 7 mit Gale
Jetzt ist alles gut
Sind wieder perfekt equipped
An Lager senden
Auch Hyper-Optimized
Eigentlich wollte ich meine Resurrection Scrolls schon
Leute ich glaube ich hab das Game gepragt
Ich hoffe ich hab keine Items verloren
So gehen wir hier raus
Kannst du mir kurz sagen wie du auf deine 4M am 2. Desktop connectest?
Einfach Hyper-V Fullscreen einstellen
Nicht 4M
Nicht
Hyper-V
Sucked
So weiter gehts
Jetzt haben wir unsere Fallen-Entschärfer-Tools dabei
Jetzt kann nichts mehr schief gehen
Wie kommst du auf Hyper-V
Also Hyper-V würdest du gar nicht benutzen
Hyper-V sucked
Zumindest für Desktop-Virtualisierung
Mag sein dass Hyper-V selbst nicht verkehrt ist
Wenn man Windows Sachen
Virtualisieren will
Ich hab noch nie Hyper-V verwendet
Weder im professionellen Umfeld
Noch privat
Weiß nicht wie es bei euch aussieht
Warum ist Kratzer weg
Kratzer sollte nicht weg sein
Also
Ich verwende keine Hyper-V
Vielleicht bei euch
Nimm 4M
Ich hab 4M Workstation auf dem 2. Bildschirm
Im Fullscreen
Gut ist
Okay
Jetzt können wir uns der Sache hier annehmen
Welche Vorteile hat 4M Workstation
Gegenüber Virtualbox
Bessere Grafik
Performance
Und ein schöneres UI
Snapshots und sowas geht glaube ich auch
Alles mit
Mit 4M
Ne mit Virtualbox
Nein
Ich will mit Will nicht entschärfen
Will
Gebe alles
High-Performer Mindset
Machen wir das jetzt lieber mit Gail
Die Frage ist
Geht so ein
Fallenentschärfungswerkzeug
Kaputt
7 Stück haben wir jetzt
Lasst mal gucken Leute
Geht das kaputt
Wenn man successvoll ist
Hoffentlich nicht
Hyper-V auf Arbeit
Weil er schon dabei ist
Ist immer die beste Begründung
Ein Hebel
Okay Hebel werden
Gepusht
Okay
Weiß jetzt nicht ob das gut oder schlecht ist
Kann man das anzünden
Man kann nichts damit machen
Kann man es
Kann man es kaputt machen
Im Zweifelsfall
Immer mal drauf ballern und gucken
Ob man es zerstören kann
Achtung Achtung
Eine Falle
Nein man verliert das
Fallenentschärfungswerkzeug nicht
Weil man erfolgreich war
Okay sehr gut
Alter wie viele Minen sind dann hier
Gail kommt da gar nicht mehr aus dem Fallenentschärfen raus
So ist hier auch
Ein Schalter
Okay
Jetzt geht das
Andere Ding runter
Aha
Jetzt müssen wir
Bestimmt den
Wir müssen
Vielleicht dürfen wir jetzt zu diesem Teil hin
Nein dürfen wir nicht
Ja nervt mal nicht
Alter ist ja gut
Zum Glück macht es kein
Damage sonst wäre ich schon dead
Alter die haben es ja echt übertrieben
Mit Fallen oder
Noch mehr
MonkaW HD
Trapped ist ja was ganz was neues
So hier gibt es nichts
Aber hier gibt es auch wieder einen Hebel
Welchen Unterschied siehst du
Zwischen einem Linux System
Wenn es jemand der Devops macht
Devops klingt cooler
Hab ich doch schon entschärft
Bevor es entdeckt wurde
Guck mal das haben wir auch runter gelassen
Wir müssen bestimmt
Alle vier Lampen runter lassen
So jetzt das hier noch
Das dürfte der letzte Raum sein
Den wir nicht gewesen sind
Die Trap kann da ruhig
Trappen wir haben den Schalter
Zum Auslösen deaktiviert
Also das ist blöde Antwort
Aber das ist tatsächlich der Hauptunterschied
Dass Devops cooler klingt
Also vieles was früher Admins gemacht haben
Ist heute viel mehr in Devops Bereich
Gewandert
Weil es immer weniger eigene Infrastruktur gibt
Und immer mehr Cloud
Also das hat große Überschneidungen
Natürlich können Leute im Devops Bereich
Eben aus der Entwickler Ecke aus der Admin Ecke
Kommen
Moment kann man mehrere Lampen buchen runter
Oh nein
Schalter Rätsel
Nein come on please kein Schalter Rätsel
Kein Schalter Rätsel
Och ne
Guck mal da drüben ist die Lampe aus
Guck mal ich hab jetzt alle Lampen unten
Alle Lampen unten
Alle Lampen an
Bis auf die hier drüben
Jetzt werden sie erstmal wieder
Geschockt
Ey das Ding ist mega nervig hier in der Mitte
So jetzt machen wir die letzte Lampe noch an
Und jetzt hoffe ich dass irgendwas passiert
Es passiert aber nichts
Okay
Dann hab ich legit
Absolut keine Ahnung
Warum ich überhaupt
Das jetzt alles gemacht hab mit dem Hebel
Nun gut
Dann gucken wir mal hier in den Raum rein
Was da abgeht
Schloss
Gale
Gib alles 15
Sollte er easy schaffen
Mit
Du darfst erneut würfeln
Hast so viel Inspiration
Okay
Ansonsten ist hier nichts
Boah
Es macht Geräusche
Da kommt jetzt gleich irgendwas
Und es gibt auch schon so
MonkaS Musik
Im Hintergrund
Sarkophag
Lass mal kurz gucken was auf der Tafel drauf steht
Okay
Nichts spannendes
Kann man hier oben drauf hüpfen
Hätte ja sein können
Aber daneben
Hier kann man doch rüber hüpfen
Wir machen jetzt erstmal den Sarkophag
Auf da ist nichts drin
Man kann hier doch rüber stelzen
Wann würdest du sagen dass man Senior ist
Weil es gibt ja hierbei keine richtigen Vorgaben
Ja so
Sobald es dir irgendeiner vor die Titel schreibt
Sobald es dir irgendeiner
Vor deine Job Bezeichnung schreibt
Letztendlich kannst du das
Nicht rein an
Die Jahre festmachen
Ich denke ich hab letztens was
Ich hab letztens was gutes gehört in dem Video
Das finde ich der hat es gut getroffen
Du bist Senior
Ab dem Zeitpunkt
Wo mehr Leute dich
Nach Hilfe fragen als du andere
Nach Hilfe fragen musst
Ich finde das ist ein guter
Satz gewesen
Da unten stellst irgendwas rum
Oder hat schon was bewegt oder
Hilfsstells
Ja das ist gut
Finde ich das ist eine richtig gute Beschreibung
Oh guck mal da
Gestellste Gegner
Die mich surprisen wollen
Ich würde sagen
Wir surprisen die
Wir surprisen die mit
Wir sollen hier mal
Ruhig hochfliegen
Wie zu dunkel
Will du hast 90% Treffer Chance
Egal ob es zu dunkel ist
Wir surprisen die mal
Mit einfachen Matrix Blasen
Und gucken was passiert
Bäm
Wait a minute
Warum heilt sich das
Das soll sich nicht heilen
Ja so ist besser
Ok Gail
Ich glaube der Gegner ist jetzt zu weit weg
Um ihm Damage zu
Ne ist nicht zu weit weg
Gegner bleibst du
Jetzt hat er es gecheckt
Aber nice
Der Gegner ist schon fast down
Ach guck mal
Gail bekommt noch
Ok gut
Will hat seinen Zug schon durch
Was ist das eigentlich
Ein Mantler
Irgendein Vieh
Was nichts kann oder
Ein Stufe 8 Vieh
Was soll das machen
Ok Gail ist fertig
Jetzt kommt das Ding erstmal
Es hat geknurrt
Kann das
Kann das Skelett
Vielleicht irgendwie hier vor
Bisschen näher dran
Und Damage machen
Moin
Ok
Gar nicht mal übel
Will
Gib ihm
Bam
Jetzt
Ok und jetzt darf mein
Mein
Pet fliegt da mal runter
Das Vieh sollte nicht da hinkommen
Aber nur das es schon mal in der Nähe ist
Ok Gail
Du kannst nicht
Ok
Ist aber doof
Gail kannst du hier rüber springen oder so
Gail weißt du was
Jump mal runter
Ich hoffe bloß nicht
Dass da jetzt noch mehr Gegner sind
Bisschen weit weg
Ist es bestimmt immer noch
Ja das war jetzt ziemlich bescheuert
Egal dann bleibt da mal stehen
Oh
Ok
What
Alter
Ich hab das Ding zu weit weg Eldrick plastert
Komm wurscht
Will gib ihm
Immer noch zu weit weg
Vielleicht von hier
Bashen
8 Punkte noch
Gail nicht tot
Nö noch nicht
Die haben ihn ja noch nicht angegriffen
Ich vermute mal
Diese Dinger verschwinden wenn ich das Vieh kille
Ich hoffe mal
Ach man ist das blöd
Ich hoffe das Vieh
Fällt nicht um
Dann ist der Turn verschenkt
Natürlich fällt es um
Was sonst
Geil
Gut dann kann ich es jetzt nicht finishen an der Stelle
Ok Gail du kannst
Runter springen
Und hier hin
Und jetzt einfach mal
8 Damage machen
Garantierte 8 Damage
Nice
Die Viecher sind auch weg easy
Goldene Truhe
Schwache Elementare
Das hab ich schon
Das bringt mir nichts
Aber
Das bekommt
Das bekommt Will
Weil das könnte
Noch sehr praktisch werden
Ja das könnte noch
Das könnte noch sehr praktisch werden
Schmeiß ich ihn dafür runter
Brauch ich nicht
Nur das ich dran denke
Das könnte noch mal sehr praktisch werden
Wenn wir ein paar Gegner ablenken müssen
So Summons sind eines der praktischsten Sachen
Überhaupt
Nicht unbedingt weil sie so viel killen
Sondern weil sie die Akku der Gegner auf sich ziehen
Deswegen war in Baldur's Gate 2
Wenn du
Viele Pets hattest
Warst du quasi unsterblich
Bin mal gespannt
Man kann doch bestimmt hier noch weiter hoch
Testen wir mal
Carla kann hochhüpfen
Ah ne hier ist nichts
Äh ist nichts
Wer steht denn da oben noch rum
Gail? Gail komm
Hüpf runter
Okay das ist eigentlich sinnlos
Das es da irgendwelche Pilze gibt
Hier geht es nicht weiter
Mal hier unten
Da ist zwei Double Doors
Und hier geht es wieder hoch
Pilz
Kann man
Kann man diese Viecher hier wegblasen
Kannste ja mal probieren
Und hier
Sind wir gestartet
Leute ich war heute wieder Rennen
Ich hatte jetzt ja zwei Tage Pause gemacht
Weil mir das
Weil mir das Bein ein bisschen weh getan hat
Ich hatte heute neue Bestzeit
7 Minuten und 6
Im Durchschnitt
Für den Kilometer
6,2
6,2 Kilometer
6,3 Kilometer gerannt
Und
Also mein Ziel ist erstmal unter 7 zu kommen
Das finde ich schon ziemlich anstrengend
Aber es macht Bock
Hätte ich nicht gedacht
Ich hab ja erst vor drei Wochen oder so
Angefangen regelmäßig alle zwei Tage zu rennen
Aber es macht wirklich Bock
Also mir fehlt das auch schon wenn ich mein Tag
Oder zwei Tage nicht laufen mag
Alter
Gail
Das war aber nix
Komm du hast so viel Inspiration
Ist Gail und Kalach coole Companions
Also Gail
Weiß ich nicht weil Gail ist mein Main Charakter
Kalach ist
Eines der besten Companions die ich
Bisher in einem RPG gesehen habe
Die finde ich mega nice
Eigentlich persönlich hätte mir
Liesel für die Party Composition
In Ticken besser gefallen
Als Kalach als Barbarian
Aber Kalach ist umgespeckt
Auf Paladin
Was auch ziemlich gut zu ihrer Story passt
Und seitdem ist das eine
Ziemlich gute Kombi
Weiß ich nicht Gail ist mein Main Charakter
Deswegen bekomme ich von der Story
Nicht so viel mit wie wenn er ein Companion wäre
Okay was gibt es hier
Gibt es
Ich Crab alles
Alles weg
Alles Crabben und alles verkaufen später
Alles wird alles geCrabbt
Ja perfekt
Gib alles her
Pilzsuppe
Tablett Teller
Teller
Trink 10 Gold pro Teller
Das lasse ich nicht hier erstmal alles weg
Du hast Gail gekillt
Wie kann man Gail killen hast du den nicht aus dem Portal
Gerettet oder wie
Ach guck mal Ratten
Da kommt jetzt was zu
Gute das Will bei mir
Mit Tieren sprechen kann
Gucken ob hier sonst irgendwas gibt
Will kann mit Tieren sprechen
Das werden wir doch gleich mal machen und die Ratten
Abchecken
Was es da so gibt
Wo ist Chico wenn man sie braucht
Mit Tieren sprechen
Hallo ihr nice Rats
Was gibt es denn hier
Was
Ganz ruhig wovon redest du zurück
Ich muss mir gleich deine Eingeweide von den Sohlen kratzen
Ganz ruhig wovon redest du da
Zurück oder ich
Muss mir gleich deine Eingeweide von den Sohlen kratzen
Also ich habe
Irgendwie die Vermutung dass das keine
Normalen Ratten sind
Man weiß ja in
Fantasy Settings nie
Wir sind mal ein bisschen Forscher
Versuch es doch da sind mehr Eingeweide
Okay wir gehen
Erstmal zu einer anderen Ratte
Gibt es nicht noch irgendeine Ratte
Die da normal
Shadow hat mit Tieren
Motiv erkennen
Dann erkenn mal Motiv
Wisdom
Moment
Warum kriegt
Shadow kein Plus bei einem Wisdom
Shadow hat
Plus 4 Wisdom
Das scheint mir nicht so normal
Zu sein
Ach Präge
Geschafft
Es hat einen großen Teil dazu
Wir waren immer hier
Es ist unser
Wir beachten es
Du gehörst nicht
Das klingt wie eine Bedrohung
Ich mag Bedrohungen
Geh weg
Mein Nest
Meine Schlange
Ich bin bereit
Ich würde gerne
Den Altar öffnen
Auch die Ratten haben den guten Sinn
Das ist der Weg der Helden
Deine Füße schlagen ihn
Okay
Will
Ah
Okay
Animal Handling erfolgreich
Will ist nice
Ich finde die alle gut
Einzigen Companion den ich nie benutzt habe
Großartig
Außer die ersten 1-2 Stunden
Und auch nicht benutzen möchte ist
Isterion
Vom ganzen
Drumherum
Aber ich generell bin keiner der auf
Vampirstorys steht
Du bist nur eine Ratte ist es klug
Mir zu drohen
Die sind aber wirklich hartnäckig die Ratten
Chat Gib
Okay
Was wollen wir machen
Wenn die Ratten einfach fireballen und weg ist
Wollen wir
Den Sarkophag aufmachen
Ich gehe davon aus sobald ich den Sarkophag aufmache
Werden die Ratten
Aggressiv werden ich meine Level 1 Ratten
Mit einem HP können wir nicht viel machen
Aber es sind ja wahrscheinlich
Keine einfachen Level 1 Ratten
Egal wir gucken hier mal rein
Ein Ort der Anbietung der
Dunkelmädchen
Darf sie den ganzen Welt
umbringen
Bleib still
Deine Beten
Fade away
Nothing comes to you in return
No soothing presence
No spiritual embrace
Only darkness
And silence
Your efforts must be inadequate
You must do more to please
Sha going forward
Okay ich hab
Advantage
Ja why not machen wir jetzt einfach
Ist das gescriptet
Weiter
Ah
Okay was haben wir
Gekriegt
Resistent gegenüber nekrotischem damage
Das ist sicherlich nicht verkehrt
Okay die Ratten
Ich lass die Ratten
Hier einfach Ratten sein
Ich muss die ja nicht killen
Also meine
In meinem Playthrough werde ich die Ratten in Ruhe lassen
Aber ich werde safen
Ich werde mal gucken was passiert wenn man die Ratten killt
Ich lad dann aber neu
Ich will einfach mal gucken was die eingebaut haben
In einem Game
Wir werden die jetzt einfach wegblasen mit einem Fireball
Und gucken was passiert
Okay nichts die Ratten sind einfach dead
Oh
Die Ratte ist tot
Hä
Wo ist noch ne Ratte
Da ist noch ne Ratte
Wie gesagt
Ich lad gleich
Ich will einfach nur wissen
Ob die sich irgendwas bei den Ratten gedacht haben
Oder irgendwas wo ich gerade zu blöd bin
Das rauszufinden
Ich lass die Ratten in Ruhe
Sollen die da mal machen
Okay
Hebel
Ich hab keine Ahnung was der Hebel gemacht hat
Schlüssel
Justizarhelm
Tagebuch
Was kann dieser Justizarhelm
Kann das was
Hä
Hier ist sonst nichts
Welche Taste ist das
Alt
Wobei das nicht bei allen Gegenständen
Guck hier unten bei den Kisten und so
Bringt das nichts
Hier ist sonst nichts
Wo gehts hier lang
Oh was haben wir denn hier
Level 7
Aber die haben nur 18 tp
Die sind ja
Die sind ja total schnell down
Okay jetzt
Jetzt stellen sie nur hier erstmal kurz rum
Unsichtbar
Dafür ist es optimal
Mein Pet
Oh Moment mein Pet
Soll dir keiner nachlaufen
Okay jede Menge Untoten
Was super ist
Wenn ihr das Turn Undead dabei habt
Hier gehts lang
Hier ist ne Schatzkammer Tür
Hier das wars
Da gehen wir jetzt rein
Und bashen die würde ich sagen
Wahrscheinlich lassen die sich nicht so einfach
Bashen
Sind die überhaupt aggressive
Die sind gar nicht
Aggressive
Taschendiebstahl
Kann mit denen reden
Sind wir mal diplomatisch heute
Ich mein alternativ
Ich
Ey
Wollt ihr grad Fireballen
Mit wem spreche ich in Wirklichkeit
Ich bin nicht euer Freund
Ah
Ob das so ne gute Idee ist
What
Oh der sieht ein bisschen stärker aus
Als die
Als die Skelette
Naja 49
Eigentlich jetzt nicht so
Wild
Aber der Gelegenheit
Gibt es
Ja
Was
Aber die gelegensat können wir nochmal
Unsere Schriftrolle rausholen
Oh es kommt immer
mehr dabei
Wait a minute
Ach
Kommt noch mehr dabei
Ok ich habs nichts gesagt
Dann sollten wir den jetzt erstmal weg
Bursten
Wil ist der einzige der am start ist
Die Ding
Die Viecher, würde ich sagen, sind nicht so gefährlich
Also entweder killen wir die
Schattenbeam
Ich glaube, okay
Ich glaube, wir müssen die
diese Portale killen, wenn wir die Portale
nicht killen, dann spawnt wahrscheinlich
unendlich viel nach
Okay, wir
Fireballen die jetzt mal da oben in der Ecke
Das schadet auf jeden Fall nie
Erst Fireballen
dann Fragen stellen
Mist, einer hat's überlebt, okay
Ey, da kommen noch mehr
Das ist meiner hier
Wenn ich Glück habe
kann der den killen, 36%
Der sollte vielleicht nicht Frontline stehen
Wait a minute
Warte mal, warte mal
Moment, Moment
Sekunde, die sind nicht alle
gegen mich?
Hab ich grad die Guten gekillt?
Hab ich die Falschen gekillt gerade?
Ja, ich hab die
Neutralen gekillt, okay, das war dumm von mir
Das war richtig dumm, ich hab die
Falschen gekillt
Und jetzt hat Will keine Spellslots mehr
Aber das ist nicht schlimm
Will wird jetzt
zwei
Eiswürfel beschwören
Um ein bisschen Schaden
aufzusaugen
So, jetzt
kommt Gale
Der könnte auch noch ein paar Sachen
beschwören, aber ich würde eher
sagen
Gale macht
Okay, nein
Gale hastet Kalak
und Kalak geht jetzt rein und
prügelt die sowas von kaputt gleich
Aber aber nicht
abcastet auf vier
Okay, du kannst hier draufschießen
Triffst natürlich
nix
Warum helfen mir diese komischen Skelette
da?
So, Kalak, jetzt
Aufs Maul gibt's jetzt
So, Passiv
Einschalten, dann hab ich zwar ein bisschen schlechtere
Trefferchance, aber mach massiv mehr
Damage
Dann
Markieren das im Bonus
Action, ne, wir hauen einfach so drauf
Wir hauen einfach so drauf
Get rekt, dead
Jetzt
Ey, bam
So muss das sein, Kalak einfach alles
One-Shotten
Moment
Warum ist Kalak tot?
Hä? Was?
Die haben irgendwie ein Damage-Schild
Wenn man die hittet
Dann
Okay, das ist
ziemlich doof
Wenn man die hittet, kriegt man irgendwie
Schaden
Okay, das ist blöd
Nun gut
Ne, machen wir nicht
Wir machen
Oh man, doch machen wir
Doch machen wir
Also ich weiß nicht, was mit den Skeletten hier abgeht
Aber nur für den Fall der Fälle
dass die auch gleich aggressive werden
Wir
Plasten hier mal alle drei
Weg
Alter
Warum machen
Was machen die so einen krassen AE-Schaden, man
The fuck
Ich bin mir
nicht so wirklich
Irgendwas hab ich
Miterwischt
Was AE-Damage gemacht hat
Das ist ziemlich blöd
Weil
Jetzt hat Shadowheart kaum noch Leben
Das ist
Das ist wirklich blöd
Ich hab kaum noch
Ich hab kaum noch Leben
Ja, das ist kacke
Ähm
Okay, mal gucken
Wie wir das jetzt
Hingewurschtelt bekommen
So, der ist fast tot
Wenn wir Glück haben
Ansonsten
Will könnte auch
Shadowheart heilen
Ich hoffe, Shadowheart überlebt
Einfach so
In der Hoffnung, Will stirbt jetzt nicht auch
Eins
Gut
Aber Gale kann ihn killen
Gale konzentriert sich noch auf Haste
Ja, dann nehmen wir einen garantierten Treffer
in Kauf und zwei auf den
Okay
Ich muss auf jeden Fall
Diese Dinger am Boden zerstören
Ich glaube, wenn ich
Diese Teile am Boden nicht zerstöre
Ich bin eigentlich blöd, ne
Ich glaube, ich muss nicht die Gegner killen
Ich muss einfach die Dinger auf Boden schließen
Ich glaube, das ist das eigentliche
Das eigentliche
Was ich machen soll
Wie viel Leben hatten das? 32
Ja, ich sollte
Ich sollte alles killen, was
Ich glaube, ich habe den Fight verkehrt
Verstanden
Na gut, Pech gehabt
Jetzt müssen wir neu starten
Ich könnte Haste abbrechen und nochmal
Damage machen hier drauf
Ob das so sinnvoll ist?
Ich hoffe
Ich hoffe, Kader kann gleich ordentlich Damage machen
Ja, du darfst hier drauf schießen
Immun, nice, gg
Kennt sich jemand mit Snort aus?
Habe ich schon ewig nichts mehr mitgemacht
Wusste ich gar nicht, dass es noch
Ein Ding ist
Game? Hallo?
Ah, jetzt
Nicht genügend Ressourcen
Ja, geil
Schild des Glaubens, ja, das wäre nicht verkehrt
Ein bisschen
Ein bisschen mehr AC wäre glaube ich
Echt nicht verkehrt
Ja
Und ich glaube, Kader hat auch einen
Kleinen Heiltrank noch
Ach, das war eine Bonus-Action
Oh, shit
Ich glaube, ich
Ich renne so weit weg, wie es geht
Das Ding kommt nicht hin
Okay, Shadowheart
Du machst jetzt das, was Clerics besonders
gut können
Spirit Guardians Radiant Damage
Okay
Das wegen Spirit Guardians
OP
What the fuck
Warum machen die Typen so krass Damage
Wenn man ihnen Schaden macht
Ja, warum?
Keine Ahnung, steht nirgendwo
Ich hab
Keinen Plan, warum das so viel Damage macht
Oh, und jetzt
Kein
Plassenschimmer
Ja, dann machen wir
Damage hier drauf
Ich glaube, wir müssen diese Dinge
Am Boden killen
Ja
Gehe ich ganz stark
von aus
Warum ist Shadowheart wieder
dran
Jetzt bin ich echt
Shadowheart war doch eben dran
Warum ist die wieder
Kleine Antwort, wenn immer du kleinen Schaden erleidest
Wirfst du ihn als doppelten
Energieschaden auf den
Ach so
Das habe ich nicht gesehen
Ach, das ist das Problem
Deswegen kriege ich so sinnlos Damage
Okay
Das macht natürlich Sinn
Wenn man das weiß
Dann sollte Shadowheart jetzt besser
Keinen gleißenden Schaden machen
Ich hoffe, mein normaler Waffenangriff
Macht keinen gleißenden Schaden
Ne, anscheinend nicht
Shadowheart, du machst jetzt einfach
Dieses Ding hier kaputt
Ja, komm, das sollst du schaffen
Boah, boah
Sechs, na toll
Okay, komm, heil dich mal
Selbst ist zwar meistens
Verschwendung
An Bonus-Action, aber
Mal gucken
Dass du es überlebst
So, jetzt aber
Down
Okay, also ich vermute
Ich vermute echt, man muss diese Löcher im Boden
Wegmachen
Auf der anderen Seite ist schon lange nichts mehr gesport
Daraus
Schauen wir mal, was passiert
Wow
Yep
Das ist aber gemein
Doch, wir müssen auf jeden Fall
Diese Dinger am Boden
Die Dinger müssen weg
Oh, oh, shit
Ich war zu langsam
Jetzt haben wir echt Probleme langsam
Okay, wir müssen
Bevor wir irgendwas machen
Diese Löcher im Boden
Ja, nice
Und wir fliehen jetzt einfach
Davor
Wo sind denn die Gegner?
Die Gegner sind da hinten
Der andere ist da vorne, okay
Goodbye, weg hier
Mit Controller
Auf dem PC gespielt, soll viel besser
Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass das wirklich besser ist
Okay, geil
Du könntest mal probieren
Die zu CC'n, ich hoffe
Ich hoffe
Ist das nur Radiant Damage?
Oder ist das auch Feuer Damage?
Nur Radiant Damage
Okay, wir können mal gucken
Ob man die CC'n kann, das wäre natürlich op
Dann ist halt meine
Backline ein bisschen mehr Luft
Nice
Zwei Runden außer Gefecht, so muss das sein
Du haust
Hier trotzdem mal ab
Du kannst Damage machen
Ja, ich hab den Fight total dämlich angefangen
Ich hab die Viecher gekillt, die mir eigentlich
Helfen sollen, richtig dumm
So
Jetzt kann ich irgendwie
100% Nachteil, ja
Den Nachteil nehme ich in Kauf
Macht kaum Damage
Next
Nee, also ich hab nur einen Xbox Controller
Hier mit USB, das könnte ich ausprobieren
Aber ehrlich gesagt, ich finde
Die Bedienung vollkommen in Ordnung mit Maus und Tastatur
Das Einzige, was ich nicht so mag, ist, dass man
Dieses komische Menü hier hat
Neben mit dieser Kette
Zwischen den Characters
Und nicht einfach
Ziehen kann, wie in Baldur's Gate 2
So
Wir haben jetzt echt so ein kleines
Problem, es werden ein bisschen viele Gegner
Wir müssen
Diese Löcher
Kaputt kriegen
Ich vermute, ich hab den
Fight verloren, weil ich
Komplett falsch angegangen bin
Ich hab Damage drauf gemacht
Auf die
Falschen Mobs
Und dann bin ich auf diese Viecher gegangen
Anstatt
Naja, gut
So
Moment
Waren die immun gegen Necrotic Damage?
Oh
Shit, Alter
Das ist natürlich doof
Wie viel Damage muss man machen?
3 bis 16
Wie mach ich den am besten mit Shadowheart
Das Ding jetzt kaputt
7 bis 42
Okay, Level 3
Sollte reichen
Boah
Max Damage, mega
Nice
Ist zwar eigentlich Verschwendung, aber
Ein bisschen
Schadet nichts
Gut
So, ihr geht hier hin und macht das Ding
Macht das Ding zu
So, wir haben noch
Wie viele von diesen Löchern haben wir denn noch offen?
Eigentlich nur noch
3 Stück
Shit
Ne, 1, 2, 3
Puh
Ja, dann versuchen wir das hier zu schließen
Okay
Nächste Runde, ist das zu?
Oh, oh, oh
Ja, geht ruhig auf meine Pets
Optimal
Ja, und schieß vorbei
Oh
Leute
Da kommt jede Runde was raus
Shit
Ich bin so dead
Kannste vergessen, ey
Ich hab...
Okay, Will
Kriegst du das Ding irgendwie weg?
Irgendwie von hier
Vielleicht
Weil die sind noch eine Runde hypnotisiert
Oder das?
Okay, das war
Dumm, Max
Weil der kann das killen
Und Will
Seriously
Das ist jetzt
Mega Damage verschenkt
Und einmal da drauf
Und noch vorbei
Na toll
Okay
Gail, was machst du?
Du konzentrierst dich
Weiter auf Hypnotic Pattern, okay
Wir müssten, wir müssten das Viech hier killen
Wie kriegen wir, also 41 kriegen wir auf jeden Fall nicht
Mit nem...
Okay, wir hauen Firebolt da drüben hin
Das macht Damage auf
Will, äh nicht Will, Gail
Du musst ein Stückchen vor
Okay
Das sollte das killen und zwei ordentlich
Damagen
Wie nicht genug Bewegungsrate
Game
Come on
Ja, geht doch
Okay, okay
Gail
Ich hoffe du hältst das aus, wenn das Ding auf
Wenn der auf dich geht
Okay, das ist das letzte was noch offen ist
Und wir haben gleich
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8
Gegner
Okay
Das könnte ein bisschen
Eng werden
Ich glaube nächste Runde sind die hier eh raus
Wobei sind die
Jetzt die Frage
Sind die noch diese Runde hypnotisiert oder nicht
Weil wenn die die Runde noch hypnotisiert sind
Die nächste Runde
Das ist ein bisschen unübersichtlich
Okay
Wenn die nächste Runde rauskommen
Ist doof
Weil dann verpasse ich extra
Damage
Wenn sie noch eine Runde hypnotisiert sind
Ist auf jeden Fall nice
Ich meine wir sind noch nicht dead
Wir können das gewinnen
Dumm ist halt nur, dass mein Cleric
Und weil ich nicht auf die Gegner geguckt habe
Schon so gut wie down sind und nichts gemacht haben
Okay, Gail
Ich überlege mir noch was gleich für dich
Nehmen wir mal den
Und lassen hier unten Damage
Also wir müssen auf jeden Fall
Die sollen ruhig auf den gehen und ein bisschen
Okay
Wunderbar, die sollen auf mein beschworenes Pet gehen
Perfekt
Okay, Kalak
Du kannst Schaden machen
Auf den
Aber please kein Radiant Damage
Okay
Habe ich irgendwas was Feuer Damage macht
Doch, Paladin, hier
Sänger des Niederstrecken, Säure, Feuer, Feuer
Perfekt
Habe ich sonst noch irgendwas was nicht Radiant Damage macht
Ich bin geneigt dazu, dass der auch wirklich
Down geht
Ne, Stufe 1 sollte reichen
Das sind 1
Egal, ich habe 2 Attacks
Was ist wenn ich
Den ausmache, den passiven
Wie viel Damage mache ich dann
Ah, viel weniger
Dann lassen wir das an
Okay, schauen wir mal
Prager
Nein
Kein göttliches Niederstrecken
Sonst dead
Hat schonmal ordentlich Damage gemacht
So, jetzt
Schalte ich das aber aus
Jetzt habe ich 65% Hit Chance
Das sollte jetzt hinhauen, das sollte dead sein
Okay, gut
Hören wir an
Ähm, okay
So, Shadowheart
Kannst du noch irgendwas machen
Kannst, Shadowheart, kannst du das
Kannst du dieses Ding hier
Irgendwie wegmachen
Ohne, ich muss safen
Weil das Game keine Sichtlinien Anzeige hat
Okay, ich habe eine Idee
Shadowheart, du gehst
Da jetzt vor
Du castest das
Hier als
Level 2
Spell und wir hoffen, dass
Wie jetzt
Hä, okay, Game, keine Ahnung
Wir prayen jetzt, dass
Das reicht
Das reicht, okay
Und
Weil ich Schiss habe
Dass sie jetzt gleich einfach alle
Shadowheart
Bashen
Misty steppe ich mit Shadowheart
Weg
Okay, Will hat so ein kleines Problem
Gleich am Ende der Runde
Ja
Und jetzt ist die Frage
Sind die noch
Nächste Runde hypnotisiert oder nicht
Weil wenn nicht, könnte ich
Einen killen davon
Oh ne, könnte ich nicht
Dann scheiß drauf
Okay, die sind die Runde noch hypnotisiert, perfekt
Oh, oh, oh
Jawoll
Mach Damage auf mein Pet, perfekt
Runde verschenkt, schön vorbeischießen
Sehr, sehr, sehr gut
Kalak, perfekt
Will, Will
Au
Oh shit, Alter
Shit, okay, wir haben echt
Wir haben echt Probleme gerade
Ich, ich muss die killen
Mir bleibt nichts anderes übrig
Die sind raus
Oder kann ich die nochmal C10
Habe ich irgendwie Glück, okay, ich kann die
Okay, wenn ich
Okay, ich muss die
Ich muss versuchen, die 3 zu C10
Dass Will wegrennen kann und nicht seine Action
Raushauen muss für
Shit
Ich muss die irgendwie
Killen noch, okay, wir probieren es einfach
Hypnotisiert
Oh, fuck
Zwei resisted
Ja, gut
Ähm
Okay, nachdem Will
eh disengagen muss
Ich würde das Ding gerne
Killen, aber ich habe halt keine Ahnung
Von wo das geht
Reicht es, wenn ich hier hinlaufe
Dann
Halt mal lieber Abstand
Kann ich
Dann, oh, fuck, ich hätte Damage machen müssen
Okay
Kalak, du musst, du musst es jetzt irgendwie reißen
Nicht genug Bewegungsrate
Warum
Warum macht mein Imp eigentlich nichts
Hätte der nicht schon längst
Was ist denn mit dem eigentlich, warum kam der nie dran
Ich habe den im ganzen Fight noch nicht einmal benutzt
Warum
Warum kam der bis jetzt der nie dran
Ach, der war nicht im Fight
Das ist auch immer ein bisschen undurchsichtig
Weil mit dem hätte ich wunderbar
Die ganzen Löcher zumachen können
Okay, Will
Will
Okay, ich weiß was Will macht
Will macht Pfeifert
Will macht sich unsichtbar
In der Hoffnung, die sehen keine unsichtbaren Leute
Und verpisst sich
Okay
So, Kalak muss
Damage machen
Vor allem muss Kalak sich ein bisschen heilen
Das ist eine Aktion
Okay, wie kriege ich
Wie kriege ich ein paar Trefferpunkte auf Kalak
Drei bis sechs heilen auf alle
Bringt nicht wirklich was
Aber das ist eine Bonus Action
Das ist ja prinzipiell schon mal nicht verkehrt
Aber ich brauche die
Ich brauche meine Bonus Action
Um da rein zu hüpfen
Okay, ich
Nächste Runde überlebe ich nette
Ich komme da gar nicht hin
WTF
Okay, da müssen wir die Runde irgendwie nutzen
Fünf Trefferpunkte für alle ist eine Action
Okay
Wir heilen uns
Bisschen healen schadet nichts
Und das ist nicht an
Wie, warum ist denn das nicht an
Das ist die beste Aura ever
So
Ohje, ob ich die Runde überlebe
Ach
Ach, wir haben noch
Wir haben Shadowheart noch
Ja, aber Shadowheart kann nichts machen, weil die fast nur Radiant Damage hat
Hmm
Okay, das ist ein ganz
Guter CC
Furcht, sind die bestimmt immun
Das könnten wir probieren
Okay, das könnten wir probieren
Ich meine, einen Gegner aus dem
Fight nehmen ist nicht verkehrt
Am besten
Letztendlich ist es egal
Irgendein hier
Die hier gehen erstmal auf mein Pet
Das ist in Ordnung
Ja, nehmen wir mal einen von den
Nahkämpfern hier
Hier, zu
Okay
Der ist weg aus dem Fight
Ich kann einen
Heal noch machen auf
Nehme ich mir auf
Ja, mach mein Pet kaputt
Äh, verdammt
Ja, gut
Das macht er auf mein Pet
Ja, das ist ne gute Sache
Mach ihm Damage
Wait a minute, der ist dead?
Okay
An was ist der gestorben?
An was ist der gestorben gerade?
Hat er so wenig TP?
Oh, fuck
Also, wenn ich die Runde, wenn ich das überlebe, ist gut
Ja, vorbei, sehr gut
Oh, nein
Oh, oh, ach
Fehlenschlag, ein Damage
Ein, okay
Nice, einen Schuss hat er noch, einen hat er noch
Oh
Alter, das ist ja ultra close
Und ich hab kaum noch Spell Slots
Gut, die müssen jetzt mal dran glauben
Will
Okay, hat Will noch irgendwelche
Scrolls
Äh, Scroll
Nee, Schrift, Schriftrollen
Irgendwas ordentliches
Flammern
Hypnotisches Muster, ja
Das ist gut
Das können wir jetzt
ernsthaft gebrauchen, zauber
Will
Die sind ganz gut CCed
Das, äh, hier drauf
Nice, alle erwischt
Poggers, sehr gut, sehr gut
Okay, nice
Das, das, das ist gut
Wir haben nur noch zwei Gegner, die müssen wir jetzt irgendwie down kriegen
Die Runde
Die kriegen, die kriegen ein
Ähm
Ich glaube, den kann ich nicht
hitten, ich bin mir nicht sicher
wie das funktioniert, deswegen muss ich mal speichern
Also ich hoffe, der wird nicht
rausgeworfen
aus diesem CC, wenn ich, wenn ich hier
ein, ein Vierer
Fireball, wir müssen, wir müssen jetzt mal Damage
machen irgendwann, ja, CC nicht schön
und gut
Aber
die müssen, die müssen jetzt mal sterben
Ich mein, ich würde
am liebsten dem Damage machen und dem
kann ich aber nicht
Weil der ist noch eine Runde CCed
Tja, was mach ich denn da
Mach ich nur dem Damage?
Eigentlich muss ich den Zweiten, okay, kann ich irgendwas anderes
machen, irgendwas Sinniges?
Spiegelbilder
Ja
Okay, ich weiß, was wir machen
Wir machen Doppel Damage, wir machen dem Damage
In der Hoffnung,
dass Gale nicht stirbt, wenn ich hier hingehe
Ach man, das reicht nicht
Fuck
Äh
Ah shit, das ist eine Bonus-Action
Okay,
verkackt
Mh, hat Gale noch
ein paar Schriftrollen?
Tödliches Phantom
Dimension Rollen könnte praktisch
sein
Langsam, okay
Das ist gut
Da haben die nur noch einen Angriff
Aber ich muss
Damage machen, die müssen, mein CC ist
schön und gut, aber ich mein, ich muss
irgendwann Schaden machen
Okay, dann
Ich mein, der Save-Play wäre nochmal
versuchen, die anderen zu CCen und dann mit Kala
rein und die weg, aber wisst ihr was?
Komm, scheiß drauf, Fireball
Guter Damage
Guter Damage, der ist jetzt natürlich wieder raus
aus
Okay, Kala
kann kein Damage machen, okay
What the fuck?
Come on
Please, hier, da kannst du
doch hinspringen, oder? Und dann hast du genug
um Damage zu machen
Eigentlich müsste sich Kala heilen
weil die ist nächste Runde down
Aber wir müssen Damage machen
Down zu gehen ist in 5E
nicht so schlimm, weil mit einem einzelnen
Heilzauber ist man gleich wieder da
Nein, kein göttliches
Niederstreckend
Okay
Passiv ausschalten, mehr Hitschance
Und jetzt, please
Dead, gut
Habe ich noch
irgendwas übrig, was ich machen kann?
Nein
Okay, Shadowheart
Kannst du noch irgendwas machen?
Die macht ja nur Radiant Damage
Der hier
ist noch weg
Ja, du kannst
Spiritual Weapon casten
Das macht kein Radiant Damage
Hier in die Mitte
Nein, Alter, wo rennst du hin?
Wir können
nochmal heilen, aber
ich würde sagen, ich heb mir das erstmal auf
Tote
Tote beleben ist eine super
Geschichte
Das lenkt die Gegner ab
Äh, okay
Warum auch immer das nicht wieder
belebt werden kann
Ist natürlich ziemlich bebega
Dass es nicht geht
Ziemlich useless Spell
Okay, kann
kann
Shadowheart irgendwas sinnvolles
machen noch
Ich würde sagen, die hebt sich ihren Spell Slot auf
Damage kann sie
eh nicht machen
Äh
Die hat nur Radiant Damage
Gucken wir mal, ob wir sie überleben
Okay, Kalak dead
Ui
Was ist mit dir los?
Jaja, geh auf die Waffe, beste
Okay, das Viech ist
wieder da
Ja, geht auf die Waffe, perfekt
Ganz top, mach weiter
Sehr gut
Okay, Will, du kannst nichts machen, außer Damage anscheinend
Du kannst das Viech hier killen
Das sollte easy drin sein
Oh, was ein Pech
Mann
Okay, kannst du noch
irgendwie ein bisschen Schaden verursachen, please?
Ja, du kannst den finishen
Ich
Ich nehm lieber
Ich nehm lieber einen sicheren
Kill
Ich glaub immer noch nicht, dass wir das
Ja
Okay, 46
Du kannst nichts mehr machen
Will, du hast schon alles
gemacht, was ging
Keiner kann draufhauen
Okay, Kalak
macht jetzt selbst Lion Hands
Nee, Kalak
macht Damage, scheiß drauf
Die muss Damage machen
Das, das, es bringt nichts
Die müssen ja sterben irgendwann
Was haben wir denn hier eigentlich?
Sengir, nochmal
Dann machen wir das hier jetzt
Hoffentlich ist da kein Radiant Damage dabei
Nee, kein Radiant Damage
Perfekt
Vorbei
Top
Das hat sich richtig gelohnt
Ähm, Schild des Klaums
Ja, ey, wenn du dann schlechter
getroffen wirst, machbar
So, hiermit können wir Damage machen
Bleeding
sind die bestimmt
immun, vermutlich
Aber wir können es ja mal probieren
Ja, dachte ich mir
Okay, Shadowheart, hast du irgendwie die Möglichkeit
den Typ zu killen?
Irgendwas?
Außer Radiant Damage
Er hat nur Radiant Damage
Necrotic Damage
sind sie resistant dagegen
Ja, das findste nicht
Luch, verfluch dir
Ich mein
Ist das eine AE-Zauber?
Ah, das ist ein Cone, das bringt auch nix
Oh, shit
Okay, weißt du was?
Shadowheart
Weißt du was?
Renn mal hier vor
dass du im Zweifelsfall ein bisschen Nahkampf Damage
gleich machen kannst
Das
Naja, wir können es mal probieren
Eigentlich ist es immer ein bisschen
Ach, da muss man ja touchen
Eigentlich ist es immer ein bisschen verschwendet
Okay, für den Sub
So, schauen wir mal, ob wir die Runde überleben
Ich find es sehr nice, dass die auf die Waffe gehen
Ja
Okay, Kalec down
Ja, sehr schön, sehr schön, Shadowheart
Perfekt
Okay, Shadowheart, du machst jetzt
eine Swords auf Kalec
Und, tja
Bless
Dass ihr besser trefft
Ja, bless auf, was weiß ich
Brauch ich jetzt irgendwie?
Ne, nicht wirklich
War Teil 1 damals schon Runden basiert?
Intern, ja
Aber
Es war
Realtime mit Pause
Okay, Will, du hast doch noch eine Schriftrolle gehabt
Du hattest doch noch
eine Schriftrolle mit Hypnotic Pattern
Vielleicht haben wir Glück
und können die nochmal C10, die Dudes
da hinten
Okay, 2, 3, jawoll
Wir haben wieder 3 erwischt, okay
Wir haben ne Chance, wir haben ne Chance das zu gewinnen
So, Will, weg mit dir
So, Kale
Du musst irgendwie Damage machen
Guck mal, ich mein so viel
Guck mal, es ist nur noch der hier, der wirklich
gefährlich ist, die anderen sind jetzt
Die hier sind 3 Runden hypnotisiert
Okay, wir machen jetzt
Feuer Damage, mehr haben wir nicht
Wir haben aber noch genug Spell Slots
Ja
Jawoll
Das war ein guter Hit
Das war ein sehr guter Hit
Kale, kannst du
den bashen?
Nein? Ach, weil du keine Aktionspunkte
mehr hast, natürlich
Aber
Der hat noch
10, okay, ich hab
ne Idee
Kale wird jetzt
down gehen gleich, aber das
ist nicht so schlimm, dafür ist der Gegner tot
Wir gucken mal
0,80%
Okay, wie viel haben wir
damit? 60
Okay, ich trau mich mal
Ich hoffe, ich hätte
Ja
Was willst du da machen?
Was willst du tun?
Würde der echte Gangster da halt sagen
Okay, Fehlschlag, perfekt
Sehr gut, sehr gut
Okay, okay
Gut, gut, vorbei, perfekt
Nice, alles gut
Okay, Will, du machst jetzt mal was Sinnvolles
Du bashst den Typen jetzt, okay
Das sollte doch für dich kein Problem sein
Ja, ist auch nicht
Nice
Will, du hast deinen Job erledigt, passt
Kale, du gehst jetzt
auf den Typ und haust den um
Am besten noch mit
extra Damage
Extra Damage ist immer gut
Alter
Kale, kannst du mal was treffen?
Was ist das?
Die hättet gar nichts
Ähm
Hm
Ich mein, dann ist Kalek tot
Ist der untot?
2 bis 16, nee, das lohnt sich nicht
Aber Gale
Gale kann den bashen
Und zwar
Also das sollte
hinhauen, wir könnten
Wie viel bringen
Abcast Magic Missiles? 8 bis 20
Nee, komm, scheiß drauf
Wir gehen auf Nummer sicher und killen den
Nice
Okay, Leute
Es sieht fast so aus, als haben wir eine Chance
das zu gewinnen
Aber wir haben noch 3 und wir sind ziemlich
ziemlich down
Wir dürfen auf gar
keinen Fall Radiant Damage
machen
Ähm
Okay, ich könnte meinen letzten
Spell, aber das ist totale Verschwendung
in den Spell Slot für
Für Heal, nee
Dann, dann
Ich hab keinen Heiltrag mehr
Das ist dumm
Wie gesagt, kann ich
Könnte ich Kalek heilen? Ja, dann
Komm, Shadowheart
Kannst du irgendwas sinnvolles machen?
Ja, du kannst was sinnvolles machen
Abbild beschwören
Dann hat Kalek
Advantage, das kannst du machen
Das ist gut, mach das mal
Und du
stellst dich auch da vor
Du beschwörst noch neue Spiritual Weapon
Ja, das ist gut, da kannst du den
Nimm den letzten Spell Slot, das ist okay
Du hast
Damage gemacht, okay
Kalek, du kannst vielleicht noch da ein bisschen hinrennen
Wenn du down gehst, ist nicht schlimm
Wir können genug Heiltränke auf dich werfen
Okay
Jetzt, jetzt gibt's Damage
Wer fängt an?
Hier
Haben wir noch Extra Schaden?
Hier, Paladin Extra Schaden, nicht Radiant Damage
Und jetzt Kalek, einfach
Einfach mal hitten, please, okay
Einfach hitten
50%, ich hab irgendwie 80%
Vorbei gehauen
Was?
By the way, solltest du nicht Advantage haben
Weil
Wait a minute
Hab ich grad den falschen Spell benutzt?
Mit Shadowheart eben?
Ich hab Abbild
Beschwören gemacht, lenke deinen Gegner ab
Und du hast
Du hast Vorteile
Warum hab ich kein Advantage?
Ich bin doch innerhalb von 3 Metern
Zu dem Abbild
Okay
Nun ja
Damage, please, treffen
Kalek, treffen
Alter
Wie unfähig kann man sein?
Okay, geht doch
Wahnsinn, Alter
Okay, Will, du kannst Damage
Machen, das ist okay, die sind alle raus
Ja, schöner
Damage, richtig gut
Okay, jetzt glaube ich, gewinnen wir das
Ich glaube, jetzt gewinnen wir das
Okay, noch 3 Stück da
Gale
94%, das sollte hinhauen
Ah
Der kann uns ja gar nicht alle killen
Okay, dead
Ähm
Shadowheart, kannst du noch irgendwie hier was machen?
Kannst du irgendwie draufhauen oder so?
Ja
Hau mal drauf
Ich hoffe, du machst kein Radiant Damage, sonst bist du gleich down
Ja, perfekt
Ja
Im Nahkampf triffst du nix
Das weiß ich auch
Kacknoob
Och nee, oder?
Och nee
Will
Warum bist du so useless gerade?
Okay, dann müssen wir was anderes machen
Chromatischer Orb
AE vielleicht?
Super, ein Zug verschenkt mit Will
Perfekt
Ich
Weg ist unterbrochen
Okay, wir müssen Magic Missile abcast
Level 2
Ah, wir sollten es eigentlich haben
Och, noch 15 Leben
Und jetzt gibt's aufs Maul
Dead Gift
Boah, Karik, du bist so unfähig
Alter
Easy win, Leute
Och nee, nicht noch ein Boss
Hört mir auf
Okay, kurz, short rest, ja?
Short rest
Okay, Leute
Alter, ultrakrasser Fight, ey
Das war echt anstrengend
Das war nicht ohne
Ich speichere jetzt an der Stellung
Geh ins Bett
Das war anstrengend
Aber man sieht, selbst
Fights, die man falsch angeht
Und die man am Anfang verkackt
Das Spiel ist nicht so schwer
Das ist der höchste Schwierigkeitsgrad
Das ist alles machbar
Weil, selbst wenn ein Charakter down geht
Du kannst ihn ja mit einem einfachen Healing Spell
Oder Trank wiederbeleben
Mir ist es heute zu 14 Minuten Überzeit gekommen
Ja, weil der Fight bis eben ging
Alles klar, Leute
Schön, dass ihr dabei gewesen seid
Morgen ist Freitag, das heißt, die Woche ist wieder vorbei
Wir sehen uns morgen
Bis morgen